WK
[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
todos muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live desse canal que eu falei que eu
tava pensando em encerrar mas aí eu
escutei o clamores de vocês e decidi só
mudar a programação do canal pra gente
não encerrar mas a gente vai fazer de um
jeito muito mais tranquilo sem uma
obrigação muito grande de fazer dois
vídeos por semana hoje eu tenho aqui
novamente comigo a Roberta Caru querida
amiga querida paciente e autora de
livros que esteve aqui conosco no canal
há quase 5 anos numa Live sobre fadiga
sobre Burnout e ela está aqui de novo
voltou para o nosso canal para nos
brindar aí com seus conhecimentos que
ela adquiriu ao longo dos anos sobre
essa tão temida situação doença que
atinge tantas pessoas já temos algumas
pessoas ao vivo a Mar de cai não sei se
fala AM decai omor de shai é chapiro
cover né e a Clari Leone Então pessoal
hoje eu não vou fazer uma exposição uma
aula sobre fadiga ou sobre Burnout a
gente vai conversar com a Roberta vamos
obter aí preciosas informações Alguém
passou por esse problema aí por muitos
anos e Obviamente as perguntas que vocês
forem fazendo eu vou respondendo com a
ajuda da Roberta Boa noite Dani Boa
noite Eliseu boa noite blanders
e seja muito bem-vinda Roberta muito
obrigado por ter aceitado o convite aí
pra gente fazer uma outra Live masine Eu
que agradeço o convite eu adoro o canal
sou inscrita seguidora acompanho o
conteúdo então fico muito feliz de ter
um espacinho aqui no canal que é sério e
que trata essas questões com seriedade
para falar sobre Burnout
Ah eu agradeço Então as palavras e
realmente o YouTube a plataforma já não
tá gostando muito mais de mim né mas
tudo bem a gente insiste mesmo assim a
gente insiste a gente é teimoso é chato
né É isso aí é perseverança as pessoas
às vezes não querem ouvir eu continuo
fingindo que tá todo mundo achando ótimo
é né Eu sou aquele cara né que vai paraa
festa sem ser convidado e todo mundo
finge que convidou né Então essa essa é
a situação que a gente se sente no
YouTube agora né porque o YouTube é
considera Persona não grata já eh muito
bem então Eh se apresenta pro pessoal
que não te conhece ainda Roberta fala do
um pouquinho da da sua trajetória eh da
sua carreira que você tinha antes e aí
depois a gente vai complementar com as
perguntas aí tá eu eh fui publicitária
durante Acho que uns 25 anos era
redatora publicitária trabalhava em
agência naquela rotina que é muito glamz
né de vir à noite de não ter horário
chegar tarde não sair nunca mais e eu
modesta parte fazia muito bem meu
trabalho me identificava com essa rotina
eh maluca e aos poucos sem me dar conta
eu fui
focando só no trabalho Fui deixando
todas as outras áreas da vida todos os
outros pratinhos caindo fiquei focada só
no trabalho e um dia eu tive um colapso
um colapso eu não sabia o que tava
acontecendo e a partir daí começa o
segundo tempo porque eu hoje vejo que eu
reconstruí a minha vida mantendo a Minha
Essência que estava se perdendo naquele
ritmo mas eh hoje mais próxima das
coisas que me trazem saúde felicidade
então eu reconstruir minha vida hoje o
meu trabalho é falar sobre Burnout eu
tenho formação de terapeuta eu estava
atendendo agora a agenda tá fechada vai
voltar no ano que vem então eu tô me
dedicando realmente a ah levar a palavra
sim que eu acho que a gente é muito mal
orientado os barnaut ados somos muito
mal orientados ainda há muita ignorância
sobre o tema Então hoje eu me dedico a
falar sobre isso e esclarecer as coisas
que na minha jornada eu vi que são
fundamentais a gente entender e que
ninguém explica não mas realmente isso é
muito importante sabe muita gente que
passou por problemas de saúde que foram
muito impactantes tiveram também
condutas semelhantes a você estudaram
muito tema e modificaram totalmente a
vida né das pessoas que passaram por
isso e puderam também passar a
informação para outras pessoas e
impactar a vida aí de milhares de
pessoas que passam por isso né é sempre
uma história muito bonita quando uma
pessoa utiliza um problema uma doença
para
eh se tornar um divulgador de
informações de alta qualidade e ajuda
tanto a a milhares de pessoas né E foi
justamente me relembrar
o papel que nós temos como comunicadores
que me fez desistir de encerrar o canal
porque muitas pessoas se manifestaram
por mais que o a plataforma não goste né
e e fique boicotando a gente tem um
papel social importante e só realmente
fazer de uma maneira que não se torne
muito desgastante né mas eu decidi parar
de olhar os números porque você ficar
olhando os números de um vídeo vai bem
outro vai mal você fica realmente
obsecado com essa com esse tipo de coisa
é Deixa de ser natural e a gente perde
mais importante que é o
impag não comenta É não e tem muita
gente que não comenta e aí um dia chega
uma mensagem e você vê que você fez
muita diferença na vida da pessoa e tava
focado né em no no desempenho no
engajamento porque o próprio marketing
digital faz com que a gente se desvie
para aí né mas eu também já passei por
isso e voltei e eu não olho mais os
números eu não uso mais técnica eu tô
muito focada na diferença que eu posso
fazer na vida das pessoas sejam elas
meia
sejam elas meia dúzia ou milhares então
eu tô com meu canal pequenininho mas eu
sei que quem tá lá tá me ouvindo e o que
eu tô falando tá
impactando não com certeza olha aqui ó
Acabou de sair do consultório aí tá
acompanhando a gente na Live um abraço
aí
Dani um beijo para
você o Eliseu aqui deve ter umas 45
perguntas
comear é um rapaz mas a gente vai fazer
o possível para responder as dúvidas
dele que mais alguns comentários aqui
iniciais Muito obrigado aqui pelo
comentário viu
clar olha só tá te acompanhando também a
Mila aí viu Boa noite
Mila boa noite a você
também bem aí o resto é mais perguntas a
gente vai começar então então falar mais
pra frente uma meia hora de Live a gente
começa a responder as perguntas tá bom
viu pessoal fique aí esperando um
pouquinho tem um pouquinho de paciência
com meia hora de Live a gente passa para
as perguntas né Então a primeira
pergunta que eu queria fazer paraa
Roberta é se ela pode nos contar sobre o
momento que ela percebeu que ela tava
realmente passando por um Burnout né
aquela vida maluca lá de agência de
publicidade e El Já atendi muita gente
desse mundo da publicidade Eu sei como é
que é complicado esse esse ambiente né
com quando você percebeu isso e que que
mudou para você a partir do momento que
você percebeu que você tava entrando em
Burnout é na verdade a minha descoberta
do diagnóstico é um pouco fora do normal
até pela época em que se deu que a gente
não falava ainda em Burnout Eu por
exemplo nunca tinha ouvido falar essa
palavra Então teve um momento em que eu
percebi que eu estava lidando com um
grande problema e um segundo momento
quando eu percebi que esse problema era
um Burnout então a o momento que eu
percebi que eu tava lidando com o
problema foi eh Na verdade eu olhando
para trás vejo que eu tive muitos
sintomas que eu não consegui reconhecer
como sendo alguma coisa mais do que Ah
tô cansada todo mundo tá cansado Deixa
para lá mas teve um dia que eu colapse
num restaurante
e achei que eu tava tendo uma crise de
hipoglicemia alguma coisa do tipo eh fui
paraar no pronto socorro não acharam
nada eu dormi e na hora que eu acordei
eu não tinha força para ficar em pé eu
não conseguia ficar em pé uma fadiga
absurda e desesperadora e a partir daí
logo não tinha como eu não aceitar que
eu estava lidando com um problema só que
eu fiquei três anos lidando com esse
problema e consultando perto de 20
médicos e ninguém descobria que problema
era todos me falavam que fisicamente eu
não tinha nada e eu simplesmente não eu
ficava pulando de médico em médico e aí
depois de TR anos eu percebi eu descobri
que esse problema que ninguém até então
tinha identificado ou aqui uma
observação minha nem levado a sério esse
interessado era um Burnout foi no
consultório de uma médica homeopata que
eu ouvi essa essa palavra pela primeira
vez foi a foi o primeiro profissional da
saúde que eu percebi que tinha entendido
o que eu tava falando e o que falava
para mim fazia sentido Então a partir
daí comecei a tentar entender o que
exatamente era o e é o que eu falei para
você mudou tudo aí aí passamos pro
segundo tempo da vida quando eu tive que
entender como eu havia chegado naquela
situação o que precisava mudar e começar
essas mudanças para para ter um um
estilo de vida qualidade de vida e uma
saúde física e mental completamente
diferente do que era antes para que eu
pudesse me sentir bem novamente né
perfeito Então quais foram os primeiros
passos que você deu para sair dessa
situação que você entrou nessa situação
totalmente nova que você entrou numa
fadiga e ficou não conseguia sair da
cama nessa exaustão e passar a cuidar de
si mesmo os primeiros passos que desse
caminho que você
começou olha nesse nesses primeiros TRS
anos os primeiros passos na verdade foi
uma redescoberta de quem eu sou porque a
minha reação natural eu acho diante de
uma situação como Aquela que eu estava
enfrentando é me fechar me encolher me
resignar e lamentar foi isso foi essa a
minha a minha a minha reação às coisas
por muito tempo mas alguma coisa
aconteceu ali que eu comecei a
questionar o que me falavam as soluções
simples que davam para mim Ah não isso
daí é não sei o qu é estress é uma ang
e eu falava não é isso não é isso então
eu comecei a descobrir primeiro a força
que eu tinha que eu tenho e que eu não
sabia porque eu precisei peitar isso e
continuar e começar a criar um caminho
que não existia
para esse o que precisava foi assim que
eu fui descobrindo eh que profissionais
que eu precisava procurar quem ia poder
me ajudar e a partir desse momento o que
eu precisava fazer na paralela então
Eh que eu dei a partir da descoberta do
que estava acontecendo foi de mudar meu
estilo de vida minha forma de pensar o
meu os meus padrões de pensamento de
comportamento os meus hábitos eh começar
a questionar minhas crenças a a olhar
com um outro olhar pras coisas que eu
tive muito como sempre foi assim sabe
então é é um questionamento que você
começa a fazer a respeito de si mesmo e
da sua relação com a vida de uma maneira
geral com as pessoas com trabalho etc
para ir entendendo nesse caos
emocional quem é você de verdade essa é
a pergunta que assombra
o sim o teu áudio tá falhando um pouco
viu eu vou perguntar até pro pessoal se
tá escutando porque começou a sumir um
pouco sua voz e falhar um pouquinho tá
eu vou colocar o microfone eh pessoal
que tá acompanhando ao vivo vocês podem
me dar um feedback do áudio da Roberta
como é que tá eu tô de fone eu vou ligar
o microfone e aí você me fala se tá
funcionando porque se tiver que mexer na
configuração aí não dá então pera aí ó
Coloque tudo bem A Elisa tá falando que
tá mal o áudio tá E assim você me ouve
ou tô muda eu escuto tô escutando Ah
então tá então então desculpa gente eu
não tinha colocado o microfone que eu
achei que não ia dar certo na
configuração perfeito feito mas eu tô te
ouvindo Tá agora o pessoal que tiver
escutando especialmente a a Maria neura
também tá dizendo aqui que o áudio está
baixo a Elisa Maria tá dizendo que o
áudio tá baixo a Cristiane AOC disse que
falhou um pouco Eita como é que tá Como
é que tá agora como é que tá a lei
melhorou
gratidão tá falando que melhorou agora
então foi erro meu Gente desculpa aí a
Cristi tá dizendo que está ok para mim
agora então resolveu resolveu que que
você fez aí pode continuar desculpa te
interromper porque senão o pessoal não
ia entender o que você tá falando Não
exatamente Tá certo eh não tem menor
ideia do que eu tava falando mas acho
que eu tinha
con acho que eu tinha concluído a sua
pergunta
é estava falando do início da jornada os
primeiros TRS anos como é que foi é Ah
sim eu lembrei é verdade eu tava falando
da pergunta sobre quem a gente é de
verdade né quando a gente se vê num
Burnout isso eh a primeira coisa que que
aparece
nas terapias e tal é quem é você do que
que você gosta e a gente descobre que
não sabe porque a gente até então isso é
típico Um clássico do borado a gente
vinha construindo uma vida pros outros
para não visionar para mostrar que a
gente pode para corresponder às
expectativas e com isso a gente foi se
afastando da nossa essência de quem a
gente é então esse o processo de
recuperação de um Burnout no fundo é um
grande processo de
amadurecimento e de reconexão com quem a
gente é esse é o propósito do Burnout
todo mundo acha que o propósito do
Burnout é fazer a nossa vida um inferno
mas não é na verdade fazer com que a
gente redescubra quem a gente é ou
descubra No meu caso eu não tinha a
menor ideia então eu tive que descobrir
quem eu sou Qual é a minha força das
coisas que eu gosto no que eu sou boa no
que eu gosto de fazer no que eu posso
impactar o mundo etc e tal coisas que eu
não tinha a menor ideia Antes quando eu
eu achava que minha vida inteira era eu
ser redatora e crescendo nos cargos nas
agências e tal é porque quando a gente
entra num trilho né que a sociedade
espera da gente a gente meio que aquela
corrida dos Ratos né que o pessoal tanto
fala né E a gente vai correndo atrás de
dinheiro de Glória de reconhecimento de
um monte de coisa e às vezes a gente se
desconecta totalmente de quem a gente é
de verdade né é eu acho que hoje assim
cultural a gente tem discursos
polarizados que são adoecedores apesar
de opostos Então por um lado a gente é
levado a acreditar que não há saída que
nós somos impotentes diante da vida que
não tem o que fazer que a gente precisa
se resignar e do outro lado que a gente
precisa vencer e chegar lá e trabalhar
enquanto os outros dormem e passar na
frente e acumular dinheiro e quando você
vai tanto para um lado quanto pro outro
você no no fundo tá se afastando de quem
você é porque você deixa de ter um
objetivo ou um propósito você deixa de
ter propósito E você começa a não saber
mais quem é você e portanto o que você
tá fazendo aqui e se você não sabe o que
você tá fazendo aqui você fica a deriva
Então se o grupo social a que você
pertence acha que a pessoa só tem valor
se ela for
Milionária é ganhar dinheiro isso eu
cansei de atender paciente aqui viu
Roberta você sabe disso né mas é até
meio Óbvio que eu vou falar mas eu
cansei de at gente milionário aqui no
consultório que deu tudo deu a família
deu a saúde deu a
tranquilidade quer dizer fez tudo pelo
dinheiro né e a pessoa tem uma vida
miserável eh Não tô dizendo que Óbvio
tem milionários aí que são muito felizes
aqui não é não tô fazendo apologia a
pobreza não tá pelo contrário se a
pessoa ficou Milionária fazendo aquilo
que ela a missão dela né ela vai tá
muito feliz obrigado mas tem muita gente
que entrega qualquer coisa pelo dinheiro
né perde a família per tudo questão do é
assim o que que é ser bem-sucedido
socialmente ser bem-sucedido é você
viajar todo ano é você ter dinheiro é
você ter o carro de luxo é você ter um
apartamento não sei onde mas se você
prer isso não convive com não não tá
nunca com a sua família não sai com seus
amigos não faz nada que te dê prazer
Isso é ser
bem-sucedido não então acho que a gente
precisa começar a a a questionar essa
noção cultural do que é ser bem-sucedido
porque isso tá diretamente ligado nesse
estado que é hoje o Brasil ser
Provavelmente o país que mais tem casos
de
Burnout sim mostra o livro aí que a d
Ana Paula já está me cobrando aqui você
não mostrou o seu livro estamos aqui ó
pera aí deixa agora vou ficar no solo
layout aqui para você mostrar montar meu
layout aqui tem o primeiro que é de 2018
que a gente falou na outra Live foi né
Ah Pera deixa eu tirar o da esse link
que eu coloquei aí na frente pessoal
antes de eu tirar o link só para avisar
esse link aí e é da numa playlist de
vários vídeos que eu falei sobre esse
assunto de vários anos atrás inclusive
um desses vídeos é a outra Live que nós
fizemos há qu 5 anos atrás Mostra aí de
novo o livro que tava tá tapando aí ó no
limite do estresse Esse é o primeiro
livro é esse aqui de 2018 isso aqui foi
um relato sincerão que eu fiz contando o
que eu tinha entendido até ali né e e
depois que eu realmente fui estudar e
entender completamente saber o que era
me formar eh começar a falar sobre esse
assunto mais profundamente daí saiu o
segundo livro que é o pequeno manual do
Burnout esse aqui é um livrão ele traz
as as 50 primeiras aulas lá do canal de
aulas que eu tenho aqui no YouTube Além
do canal de
vídeos aliás vamos fazer aqui um Jabá
então eu ter que mudar o nome do livro
pequeno pomulo manual do é o enorme
manual do Burnout aliás eu aviso aqui
quem tá assistindo que o livro é
dedicado ao D Lan olha só essa foi uma
grande honra viu essa foi uma grande
honra mas você devia ter dedicado ao Dr
Alan e o Dr fofinho também ué não doutor
fofinho na não quem for assistir a outra
Live vai ver que na época eu era
paciente do drout fofinho e eu relutei
muito em largar o Dr fofinho mas quando
passei a ser paciente D Alan acho que
foi um ano depois da Live Eu lembro que
eu falei ah eu devia ter vindo antes não
tudo bem por isso que o fofinho não
ganhou mas o fofinho eu eu tinha
colocado um agradecimento no primeiro
livro e des porque na época ele era
muito importante para mim não ele foi
muito importante né ele foi muito
importante na sua recuperação a gente
não pode aí lógico que a gente não vai
falar o nome do dror fofinho tá Pessoal
vocês vão ficar vocês vão continuar
pensando Quem é o Dr fofinho
mas eu acho engraçado porque a a Roberta
é ótima para dar apelido entendeu pros
médicos né eu não faço ideia Qual que é
o meu não quero saber
não não eu nunca é uma coisa horrível só
é horrível quando é por exemplo tem uma
médica que é a doutora ins obviamente
ela não é mais minha médica Então fique
tranquilo é a Nea tá perguntando se
encontra o livro em livrarias físicas
eh sim não não você só consegue comprar
online e o livro tem digital e físico Ah
tá e online onde no Amazon aqui qual
qual livraria é na Amazon na tem tem
várias no Mercado Livre a Saraiva também
deve ter são várias mesmo E se ela puder
entrar ou no meu canal ou no Instagram
tem um link direto lá para poder
comprar beleza bem eh obviamente eu acho
que você já começou a tocar nesse
assunto mas fala um pouquinho mais para
nós o que que te inspirou a escrever o
primeiro livro e o segundo livro sobre a
sua experiência e ajudar outras pessoas
a lidarem com Burnout é na verdade a
minha a minha inspiração é a mesma tanto
pros livros quanto para qualquer
conteúdo que eu faça que são duas coisas
a primeira é como a gente é mal
orientado de uma maneira geral ao chegar
bado num consultório de um médico ou de
de um psicólogo na grande maioria das
vezes a gente é muito mal orientado
Então eu queria
escer coisas pras pessoas que me ouvirem
não precisarem passar pelo que eu passei
ou seja tanto tempo com tanta
dor a isso a minha
proposta e também de uma maneira mais
Ampla eu acho que se entende ainda muito
pouco na medicina convenci
eu acho que parte meu papel de quem fala
as coisas que fazem sentido sobre
barn um pouco essa essa pasmaceira
porque eu tô vendo que a grande maioria
dos médicos entende que eles já sabem
tudo sobre barn que basta dar um
antidepressivo que tá tudo certo e aí
cria-se esse mito que tá ficando cada
vez mais forte de que não tem cura de
que só tem controle de que você tem que
lidar com a fadiga para sempre quando na
verdade é uma abordagem errada parte de
quem tá tratando então eu eu gosto de
deixar isso claro e de esclarecer isso
para quem vai procurar essa ajuda para
que a pessoa não precise passar pelos
que eu passei eh perdida e ouvindo
besteira eu fiz sabe eu fiz tratamentos
que deixaram a minha situação muito pior
do que já estava então a minha proposta
sempre é é queimar a etapa para quem
tiver começando essa jornada não precisa
passar pelo que eu passei Olha tem
alguns relatos aqui Eu também percebi
que o teu áudio voltou a sumir tá eu
acho que talvez o problema não seja o
microfone seja você vê que o o o áudio
só que tá falhando não é imagem tá é não
tá travando aí mas mas não tem o que
fazer porque eu tô com tudo melhor
ligado aqui você tá no você tá cabeada
ou tá no wi-fi aí como é que tá no wi-fi
no meu computador não dá para entendi o
seu não tem cabo né Tem como cabiar é
não tem mas se não tá travando a imagem
deve ser a questão do som mesmo né mas é
Não tudo bem eu entendi o você falou não
eu eu falhou un um pouquinho mas o que
falhou para pelo menos para mim não
atrapalhou o entendimento tá tá mas se
tiver al vamos tocando assim vamos
tocando assim peru Alguma coisa Manda aí
que eu repito e já peço desculpa mas não
sei nem por Mas peço desculpa porque
agora já estão já estão reclamando do
meu áudio tá falando que tá muito a Ah
isso isso mesmo vamos focar no problema
do áudio dos outros é verdade a a aquela
história né a culpa é minha eu ponho em
quem eu quero né cer exatamente e o
canal é seu a culpa é sua a culpa é
minha deixa eu ajustar o o volume do
microfone
aqui pronto talvez fique melhor assim tá
né É que eu atendo muito paciente surdo
Aí eu joguei o o o ganho do microfone lá
em cima entendeu então ai meu Deus é
agora acho que deve ter reduzido um
pouquinho o áudio aqui
né Beleza
Ah então tá você já falou da sua
inspiração tá bem claro eu acho sobre
isso né então vamos paraa próxima
pergunta existem sintomas ou sinais
específicos que você percebeu que
poderiam ser alertas importantes eh para
você ajudar as outras pessoas que você
tem ajudado para as pessoas identificar
né o Burnout antes de chegar a um ponto
que vai ser muito mais difícil tratar
Então você isso você ensina isso à
pessoas baseado na sua experiência
pessoal ensino e eu ensino também uma
coisa que eu vejo que que entende-se de
uma maneira geral muito errada que é a
questão das pessoas entenderem que o
Burnout é o colapso em si quando na
verdade a gente vem sempre
necessariamente de anos de estress
crônico e aí se nada muda
a gente entra em Burnout e aí se nada
muda a gente colapsa né então assim eh a
gente ficar atento para tentar não
chegar ao colapso E aí o que eu acho que
poar é a questão de a gente descansar e
a bateria não recarrega Então você
descansa você vai dormir mas você mesmo
quando você consegue dormir você não
descansa você não acorda descansado eh a
dificuldade para dormir por se si
própria uma ansiedade que tá muito Fora
de Controle uma angústia e uma
reatividade que quando a gente tá em
estess crônico a gente é muito reativo
né então é como não sei se vocês viram
aquele meme do Tá chegando uma moto que
vai estacionar na própria garagem uma
moça que tá na rua já acha que vai ser
assaltada sai correndo gritar anda
desesperada Essa é a reatividade do de
quem tá em stress crônico Então tudo a
gente reage com muito exagero e
normalmente depois vem uma culpa vem uma
vergonha vem um ai não sei o que tá
acontecendo comigo quando a gente tá em
stress crônico também o que o que a
gente tem que observar é que a gente
fica meio com uma visão de túnel então a
gente perde a capacidade de de achar as
oportunidades de planejar as coisas fora
do curto prazo então a gente só fica
vendo urgente focado no que pode dar
errado no que pode dar ruim no que a
gente tem que fazer sempre na defensiva
também né a gente começa a se enxergar
não é que começa Eu acho que isso é uma
caracter de quem burna mas que fica mais
Evidente quando a gente tá no processo
perdão de de de de
Burnout uma palavra que a gente começar
a se a se enxergar impotente diante da
vida é aquele famoso não não adianta eu
fazer nada que nunca eu consigo melhorar
a minha situação né essa situação de
impotência que é na verdade o que mais
estressa né e a gente se sentindo como
não sendo bom o suficiente sem saída sem
tiva eh tinha um quadrinho que era um
cara que chegava no trabalho e falava Ah
eu não aguento mais e jogava todos os
relatórios para cima as folhas
espalhavam aí ele falava catando as
folhas não brincadeira vou precisar
disso daqui então essa sensação de Eu só
não jogo tudo para cima porque eu vou
ter que voltar e catar eu acho que é o é
típico de alerta de que você precisa
começar a entender o que que tá
acontecendo e procurar ajuda correta
porque fatalmente você tá num processo
de de Burnout
bem vou aproveitar aqui apresentar a
pergunta do Eliseu senão ele vai ficar
chateado comigo e deve ter mais umas 43
perguntas for essa Vamos responder isso
aqui síndrome de Burnout é esgotamento
físico mental e psicológico sim Eliseu é
um esgotamento físico mental psicológico
quer acrescentar alguma coisa É eu
sempre eu sempre explico que é um
colapso geral físico mental emocional é
quando
eh é quando o cérebro Desliga a chave
geral falando eu não tenho mais recursos
a gente vai a partir daqui atuar no modo
sobrevivência Se vira aí meu filho ou
seja não dá para você diferenciar se o
problema é físico é tudo tá acontecendo
tudo junto e
misturado exatamente no começo do canal
há uns 8 anos atrás eu fazia vários
vídeos sobre a questão adrenal né da o
que a gente chamava na época de fadiga
adrenal e que a gente mudou esse nome tá
Porque não é muito adequado eh seria uma
disfunção do eixo hpa hipófise
pituitária
adrenal Então existe vários componentes
na na Fadiga Crônica você tem a o
aspecto hormonal o aspecto sistema
nervoso central que estão muito
conectados a parte hormonal e do sistema
nervoso central e tem o lado psicológico
tud tá tudo embolado realmente porque
não tem uma um limite Claro entre o que
é psicológico O que é orgânico o que que
é hormonal o que que é neuroendócrino o
que que é
é tudo misturado Então hoje uma
abordagem para um Burnout tem que passar
por uma avaliação endócrina e tem que
passar também tanto tió quanto adrenais
tem que passar por uma avaliação também
seev central e tem que passar por uma
avaliação psicológica e tem que também
eh atuar a nível de mitocôndria né você
atacar aí a parte mitocondrial da Fadiga
que é muito importante né aqui realmente
sim Eliseu quem tem Burnout dorme mal
você quer falar um pouco sobre a Eu
Virei a rainha da insônia gente eu devia
ter um canal escrito slip em São Paulo
porque eu tive bastante bastante eu tive
tanto problema de insônia que eu tenho
um tpte hoje que tá sendo tratado um tpt
complexo por conta da insônia graças a
Deus um problema que não existe mais
graças a Deus e d Alan Muito obrigado a
gente no no stress crônico está num
esquema de alerta nosso sistema de luta
e fuga tá sempre hiper vigilante
preparado para qualquer perigo ameaça
focando no que pode dar ruim e aí eu
pergunto para você imagina que você tá
numa guerra você é um soldado na guerra
E aí você tá fazendo turnos com seus
amigos cada um dorme enquanto o outro
vigia você acha que você consegue dormir
se você não confiar que o cara que tá
vigiando é bom que ele não vai dormir
que ele vai conseguir reagir te chamar
você não dorme porque você tá em Alerta
então o stress crônico deixa a gente em
Alerta e estando em Alerta o alerta é o
oposto de sono profundo Então você tem
muita dificuldade para dormir e quando
dorme Não descansa é muito legal é uma
delícia né É
[Risadas]
dela sim Eliseu exatamente cara tá
falando aqui né você fica em estado
eterno de Fight or flight fogo luta né
que em português é fug luta em inglês
Fight or flight que é realmente você tá
sempre achando que tem um leão a a
preces a te atacar né é eu costumo fazer
uma desculpa perdão fala eu atropelo é
que eu faço uma metáfora que é assim
imagina que você Eliseu é uma casa e aí
você tem um alarme que você configura
para que ele comece a berrar Só se
alguém invadir sua casa se alguém pular
o muro para invadir sua casa e portanto
sua vida vai est em perigo só que o
stress crônico ele desconfigura esse
alarme E aí o alarme começa a tocar se
passar uma borboleta Se começar a chover
se tiver uma pessoa no quarteirão
seguinte entendeu Então traz isso para
nosssa saúde e a gente tá sempre
quicando pela parede tentando reagir e
controlar nossas reações é um caus
emocional porque a gente tá nessa
hipervigilância o tempo todo e esse é um
esquema que e quando vira crônico Não
não é uma coisa que volta sozinho que
naturalmente a gente precisa
reconfigurar por isso a gente precisa
fazer eh o tratamento médico a terapia
mudança de estilo de vida tudo junto
misturado agora tem uma pergunta dele
aqui que eu acho que deve ser uma piada
não é possível mas mas achei
interessante eu não acho que é piada
não porque o o que eu entendi dessa
pergunta é o seguinte a gente perde
tanto a noção e o foco fica tanto na
reação e no desespero que até um iPhone
16 que é uma coisa que depois que quebra
você fala meu deus o que que eu fiz eu
não tenho como repor é né primeiro você
age e depois você percebe é o que eu
falei da reatividade imagina que a a
amídala aqui no sistema límbico virou a
Vera verão lembra da Vera Verão Sim
lembro E aí ao invés dela falar gente
Atenção perigo ela
fala é isso que acontece entendeu então
a gente primeiro faz e depois você fala
ai meu deus o que que eu fiz aí vem a
culpa vem a vergonha e então sim quem
tem síndrome de banal Ach é capaz de
jogar um iPhone 16 na parede aí depois
vai parar no pronto socorro infartando
[Risadas]
né ai boa noite acho que é Jass né jazi
né pronto falei para você que era 43 não
tava brincando não mas o Eliseu é dos
meus Eu sou perguntadeira tava brincando
falei que era T3 não tava zoando não
a dor de cabeça tem várias causas
diferentes quando a causa é a síndrome
do Burnout Burnout é com bu viu Burnout
Qual suplemento tomar para eliminar a
dor não é bem assim Eliseu não é tão
assim direto né logicamente com a dor de
cabeça tem atencional cefaleia
atencional que pode acontecer junto com
Burnout nesse caso a primeira coisa é
você técnica de achamento meditação para
você controlar a origem dessa dor de
cabeça que é a cefaleia tensional aí
depois você logicamente você tá morrendo
de dor de cabeça vai tomar o analgésico
não tem nada contra tomar analgésico de
farmácia contanto que seja por um tempo
limitado e não seja uso contínuo porque
a pessoa vai ter algum problema renal ou
pode ter outros problemas de saúde eh
problema no fígado problema renal
problema no estômago então não deve
ficar tomando analgésico
antiinflamatório por tempos muito
prolongados mas tem vários inflamatórios
aí naturais você pode estar utilizando
para a longo prazo se te for necessário
se você não vocêa dor de cabeça não
conseguir ser controlado aí por mudança
estilo de vida de melhora de meditação
etc e tal é você usar uma corcumina de
alta absorção abuela serrata o pé que é
o pil etanolamina é muito bom muito
interessante o próprio canabidiol é um
monte de coisa dá para usar aí para
ajudar a controlar isso ah essa pergunta
aqui eu acho que se até o fim dos dias
vai ter vai
depois do do cataclisma nuclear e as
Baratas sobraram e as Baratas perguntar
pra outra vai vai ficar
gravada e quando tem algum curso para V
aquelas lives para vender curso tem
certificado T só falar um negócio pro
Eliseu Eliseu vai depois que acabar a
Live no meu canal de aulas e Roberta
Caru o nome e a aula mais recente é
sobre meditação já que o Dr Alan falou E
aí você primeiro Tenta ver se fala da
fala da da Macarena lá que
eu uma vez eu dei a dica pra Roberta
Caruso de um curso que tinha de
modulação no est uma dica não Você
salvou minha vida não é que o seguinte
Fala aí ela ela
carinhosamente deu o apelido como é que
é da doutora da Macarena né da Macarena
como é que é a vozinha da Macarena coisa
assim que você falou não Tiazinha da
Macarena a Tiazinha isso isso não é que
é o seguinte eh eu Eu mencionei o
tratamento que eu fiz errado e deixou
tudo pior do que era né então assim
grosso modo na minha explicação leiga
desconfigurou meu sistema límbico que aí
era eu não podia andar subir um lance de
escada apertar o passo para atravessar
rua porque tudo isso fazia com que o meu
sistema de alerta enlouquecesse e eu
ficava sem dormir à noite seguinte
inteira e a segunda noite depois disso
mesmo eu tendo tido um dia tranquilo eu
demorava ainda umas 3 horas para pegar
no sono né então eu virei uma senhora de
90 anos que andava devagarzinho que não
podia ir a pé lugar nenhum e durou
muitos anos né E todos os médicos para
quem eu relatei o que tava acontecendo
só teve um que não debochou que foi o
fofinho mas também não achou uma solução
mas ele não debochou porque os outros
davam muita risada na minha cara tipo
como se eu tivesse falando olha descobri
que tem uma cabra na sala resolve Bernal
Hum quando eu cheguei no Dr Alan eu tava
desesperada com isso gente mas era
desespero eu lembro de uma consulta que
a gente fez online que eu não consegui
ir porque eu não tinha dormido Eu lembro
até a roupa que eu tava que eu tava
quase chorando que eu falei meu Deus do
céu como é que eu vou me livrar disso E
aí ele me mandou uns links porque foi
pesquisar descobriu algumas coisas que
ele achou que poderiam ser legais e
entre esses links tinha um protocolo de
neuroplasticidade de uma mulher
maravilhosa que mora no Canadá que tinha
um problema sério de uma
hiperalerta ess dor ela até convulsionar
já convulsionou porque passou perto de
um produto forte de limpeza e tal então
ela desenvolveu um protocolo de
neuroplasticidade que eu comecei a fazer
são eu apelidei de Macarena Porque você
coloca umas folhas de papel no chão para
marcar como se fossem estações de um
circuito e você vai repetindo palavras
frases e gestos eh numa mesma ordem eh
nesses passos que estão marcados no chão
né Então você começa tipo assim meu
cérebro Sei lá o qu meu sintoma e você
vaier eu falei gente isso aqui é a
macarena porque você vai andando e você
vai fazendo uma coreografia é an Hopper
né Você fez o programa da DR an Hopper é
chama retraining the brain podem me
chamar que eu mando eu tenho in dynamic
neuro retrain System não era isso
dynamic é não me lembro é tinha umas
letra Eu Só guardei o retraining the
brain que é
retreinar do sistema olí e é uma hora
por dia você fica dançando a macarena só
que foi isso que resolveu eu
simplesmente não tenho mais esse
problema perfeito eh Então pessoal só
respondendo a dúvida aí que sempre fica
gravado a não ser o dia que o YouTube
resolve me expulsar da plataforma e
deixa de ficar gravado mas até lá vai
ficar sempre gravado os vídeos viu Tá
sim Eliseu causa depressão e causa
ansiedade Eu acho que o Eliseu tá
fazendo aqueles aqueles papelzinhos sabe
de que o americano gosta de fazer para
estudar pra prova que escreve a pergunta
na na frente e atrás a resposta né como
é que é o nome daquele cartãozinho
esqueci agora ah eu não sei
é mas é uma téc de estudo isso daí acho
que ele tá fazendo
isso mas sim eles causa depressão e
causa ansiedade né
ã aqui ó jasi perguntando aqui jazi né é
o problema é a medicina convencional
dizer que adrenal não sobrecarrega
lógico ela sobrecarrega carrega né e não
existe fadiga existe sim só que a gente
não deve usar mais o temo fadiga adrenal
já ten vários anos que eu não uso porque
e realmente a gente quando uso essa esse
termo a gente tá dando combustível tá
dando lenha para falar mal né então
vamos usar o Tero correto que é
disfunção do eixo hpa apesar de ser um
palavrão né é eu acho que o problema da
medicina convencional É acreditar até
hoje que o Burnout é um simples
transtorno de humor e que por isso só
tem controle e que o anti antidepressivo
né eu eu cheguei você viu quando eu
cheguei no Dr Alan o meu intestino tava
que meu Deus do céu e ninguém nunca
olhou ninguém nunca se preocupou em
olhar meu intestino porque todos estavam
muito preocupados em me convencer que eu
não queria aceitar que eu tinha um
problema psiquiátrico
né Isso é um problema muito sério porque
assim essa compartimentalização da
Medicina que eu tanto combato hoje em
dia é justamente isso porque é como se
você fosse um cérebro andando na rua um
fígado andando na rua um coração andando
na rua e aí o camarada ele não pensa que
sabe que as coisas estão interligadas né
não é assim de né Ah você é pelo fato da
pessoa ter um componente do problema
dela ser psiquiátrico É ela tem que ir
pro psiquiatra não vê mais nada dane-se
o resto e vai pro psiquiatra Enche meu
saco né é ass Inclusive eu costumo falar
quando a gente vai no médico
convencional com quadro de Burnout
aberto você tem duas possibilidades que
são as mais possíveis possibilidades
possíveis parabén cérebro é você ir
parar num psiquiatra tratando uma
depressão que muitas vezes você não tem
ou você parar num reumato tratando uma
fibromialgia que muitas vezes você não
tem e quando você não melhora eles
atribuem o fracasso do tratamento a você
você que não quer sarar você que tá
muito ansioso não é eles não são eles
que que que erraram Então eu fico gente
no meu conteúdo quem me acompanha aqui
sabe eu fico o dia inteiro é médico
integrativo é médico integrativo é
médico integrativo porque é isso ou
então Os caras vão ficar fazendo você
pular de médico em médico pegar um
sintoma Como foi o meu caso desse desse
tratamento errado que eu acabei de
mencionar aí que só sarou com a macarena
eles pegam um sintoma e atribuem tudo
que você tá sentindo a esse sintoma só
que o sintoma não é causa se fosse causa
não seria sintoma Então esse que é o
problema
perfeito então isso aqui são as medidas
que o Dr eh Wilson né ele começou a
divulgar há uns 15 20 anos atrás que
realmente funciona muito bem o sal
integral o James Wilson que começou a
divulgar isso aí sal integral uso de
vitaminas Complexo B magnésio tudo isso
ajuda bastante vitamina C muito
utilizada pela adrenal então isso vai
ajudar bastante na parte adrenal da
Fadiga Crônica viu todas essas dicas aí
que Bastião tá falando e que estão
naquela playlist que eu coloquei o link
aqui no começo da Live deixa eu colocar
de novo
aqui então Pessoal vocês que querem ver
os vídeos anteriores sobre fadiga
crônica sobre Burnout sobre questões
adrenais ou mitocondriais assistam essa
playlist aí tá que tem as nossas lives
anteriores uma delas com a própria
Roberta que nós fizemos há 4 5 anos
atrás
eh vamos vamos continuar aqui com as
perguntas boa noite estou escrevendo um
trabalho nesse tema legal Elisa trabalho
de qu de pós-graduação de TCC término de
curso fala pra gente mais sobre
isso não querem olhar para adrenal eles
querem te passar antidepressivo verdade
é verdade
[Música]
eh eu nunca fui workaholic mas eu me via
numa situação em que não era possível
não trabalhar aquele tanto pela área em
que eu trabalhava eh pela minha
necessidade de validação externa de
corresponder à expectativa de mostrar
que eu podia então você vê que é um é um
comportamento que não fazia com que eu
fosse work holic inclusive um grande
trauma que eu tenho é porque eu não
tinha horário eu tinha que Virar Noite
Eu às vezes virava duas três noites e
isso para mim era terrível o work holic
tem prazer nisso Eu nunca tive mas veja
como o meu comportamento fazia com que
eu não achasse saída para aquela carga
de trabalho então o Burnout acontece
quando você tem necessariamente a soma
de três coisas que são uma sobrecarga
alta um ambiente hostil e uma
inabilidade emocional da gente de
conseguir lidar de maneira saudável com
sobrecarga alta num ambiente hostil ou
seja de não conseguir sair ficar
tentando aguentar firme tentar tentar
fazer as pessoas nos tratarem de uma
maneira melhor entende então não é tão
simples assim essa conexão de Ah quem
tem Burnout é o work holic não quem tem
Burnout é quem tem uma inabilidade
emocional de colocar um limite no que
está claro que tá fazendo mal porque não
queremos decepcionar Porque queremos
corresponder à expectativas Porque
queremos mostrar que a gente pode etc
etc perfeito ótima
explicação exatamente quando você está
no comeo do quadas vezes você não
percebe vi e exatamente está comentando
aqui que a Roberto já falou existe too
esse preconceito esse diagnóstico
né Qual que é o significado de Burnout é
exaustão não sei se está perguntando Mas
é exaustão acho que é
isso o significado literal de Burnout é
exaustão é que Burn out é quando você
esgota os recursos de alguma coisa
quando esses recursos são queimados de
dentro para fora ou seja no final das
contas quando você tem um esgotamento é
exaustão ou esgotamento né são termos
equivalentes É verdade é muito fácil dar
um diagn acho que errado você tem
razão não não tem nada a ver Lisa essa
doença aí que você tá mencionando é um
tipo de demência não é uma demência
muito comum é uma demencia de dificílimo
tratamento é pior do que o Alzheimer tá
é um grande desafio essa doença aí mas
eh Lógico que qualquer fonte de estresse
pode aumentar o risco de demência tá é
bom explicar isso mas não é que é eh
necessariamente quem é estressado vai
ter demena for temporal Geralmente quem
tem alheimer Um dos fatores mais
importantes é o stresse crônico mas a
demencia front temporal é uma é uma
doença ainda que ainda tem muitos
desafios diagnósticos e não se
exatamente porque ela acontece e com
certeza o estress é um dos fatores que
levam o a desenvolvimento dessa
síndrome Não já já desisti de desistir
viu
jaz mas assim eu não vou mais fazer
naquele ritmo que eu fazia não e ficar
preocupando com o número porque a Fan B
Neil Se eu colocar
ah cor a cor azul vai vai melhor um
pouco 5% se eu colocar eu assim de de
perfil vai vai melhorar um pouco mais eu
tô já cansei dessa neura de de números
aí essa neura de de marketing digital
sabe Tô de saco cheio desse troço mas eu
vou eu vou continuar com o canal
sim metas inatingíveis contribui com
certeza né né Eliseu Com certeza né você
tinha muita meta inatingível lá na
agência
na verdade eh eu trabalhava na criação
né então criação não tem meta a criação
ela a meta é você aprovar que assim é
assim dentro do mercado da publicidade
tem as agências de marketing promocional
e de publicidade normal que todo mundo
conhece as de marketing promocional elão
concorrência chamam cinco seis
s para que cada uma desenvolva uma
solução para aquele briefing E aí quem
for melhor né dentro do do da avaliação
do cliente leva aquela conta então a
meta é ganhar o maior número de
concorrências possíveis né mas isso
sinceramente no trabalho de criação
Claro que tem uma pressão e tem um
aumento ali de de de carga e tal mas é o
de menos O negócio é você conseguir
eh lidar com o seu ego com a as
interrupções com a falta de objetividade
e com a infantilidade eu acho que que
são os principais problemas dentro de
uma agência para quem tá na criação sabe
o desrespeito por exemplo vou dar um
exemplo tem uma Vamos fazer uma reunião
hoje às 10 vamos a reunião começa 8 da
noite você passou o dia inteiro sem
fazer nada só apagando e aí a gente faz
a reunião muda tudo vai todo mundo para
casa e a gente vira à noite para fazer
entendeu então isso é o mais pesado no
nosso
caso
perfeito
aí de novo aqui o link tá pessoal que
quer assistir os vídeos anteriores que
eu falei muito sobre esse tema no
passado né tem 8 anos que eu falo sobre
esse
tema obrigado viu
jazi boa noite obrigado
Elisa
H até o Rafael escapela já tinha
recomendado e falado sobre esse
excelente conteúdo qual conteúdo o meu
conteúdo ou da Roberta ou dos dois o o
Rafael escapela é um youtuber que faz
fala sobre viagens tá ele viaja o mundo
inteiro ele é um Nô digital ele tem tem
um conteúdo muito bom também sobre
eh ensinar as pessoas a trabalhar online
né tanto com produção de conteúdo com
YouTube e várias coisas né nós já
fizemos uns vídeos juntos né porque eu
também eu acompanhava ele como eh
espectador do canal dele e a gente
acabou se conhecendo no Panamá então eu
acabei fazendo uma live com ele
ã pessoas com Burnout se sentem como
Fantasmas no trabalho pergunta
específica Essa
não
é eu é exatamente é muito específica eu
não sei o que que você quer dizer com se
sentir será que é se sentir invisível as
pessoas meio que não ligando para você
se sentindo como sei dispensável talvez
existe uma uma um problema aí na nossa
autoimagem e na relação com o trabalho
sim é eu acho que tem um nome oficial
que é despersonalização que é meio que
eu tô aqui mas só meu corpo que tá minha
alma não veio é meio Talvez seja isso El
quer dizer né despersonalização né acho
que é isso né
É É verdade isso aqui né Você sentiu o
preconceito Nossa famía não quer dizer ó
eu considero minha família minha mãe
minha mãe foi a pessoa que ficou do meu
lado o tempo inteiro sem e achar que eu
tava falando besteira ela foi a pessoa
que acreditou em mim o processo todo mas
por exemplo eu tenho tios médicos que
não fazem mais parte da minha vida
justamente por conta de como foi lidado
esse assunto nas conversas entre nós
então eh sabe o que que é ô ô
jaze culturalmente a gente é adestrado
desde cedo a ser muito produtivo a estar
sempre ativo
a sempre ocupado sempre correndo fazendo
tarefa nos deixando por último
priorizando tudo resolvendo sendo assim
os maravilhosos né quando a gente
Burnout as pessoas entendem já que a
reserve aqui como o entendimento da
medicina convencional É de que Burnout é
apenas um transtorno de humor
controlável que em duas semanas você
pode voltar à sua vida normal quando a
gente Burnout as pessoas entendem que é
preguiça que é moleza que a gente não
deu conta que nós estamos arrumando
desculpa para não trabalhar entende por
conta dessa cultura do trabalho enquanto
Eles dormem e para mim foi uma enorme
lição sobre mim eu aprendi a lidar com
isso porque no início era um negócio que
me machucava mas assim eu ficava sem
dormir eu batia a boca Nossa mas me
machucava demais e aí aos poucos eu fui
aprendendo que toda crítica em primeiro
lugar toda a crítica é uma confissão da
pessoa então o que ela está falando para
você é uma coisa mal resolvida com ela e
a segunda coisa que eu aprendi é o
famoso sido eu toma que é teu então se
alguém falou e machucou você leva para
ter terapia que parte de você tá
concordando porque culturalmente a gente
é ensinado a concordar isso é muito
importante viu que você tá falando isso
é muito importante você tá falando
porque assim quando alguém chega para
você imagina que você tá andando na rua
aí você encontra um cachorro de rua
qualquer lá ele começa a latir para você
que agressivamente né obviamente se você
percebe que esse cachorro é pequenininho
que ele não tem dente na boca que ele
não é agressivo você dá dá dá risada
dele ó cachorrinho aí maluco aí né você
não dá bola para um cachorro que você vê
que não vai te atacar que não vai
e enfim causar um dano em você agora se
for um dma se for um cachorrão grande aí
é outra história né Aí você vai ficar
com bedo cachor é mas eu acho que deixa
eu dar um outro exemplo porque eu acho
que assim se você virar para mim agora e
falar assim nossa Roberto Mas tá
ridículo esse seu cabelo azul meu cabelo
não é azul eu vou fala gente coitado
ficou doido Pois é é agora se você virar
para mim falar assim nossa tá gordo hein
vai doer em Porque isso é uma coisa que
eu ainda não sei lidar exatamente mas
esse é o ponto tranquilidade então é
quando você sabe que o que tá sendo dito
é absurdo você não liga entendeu quando
afeta muito a você é porque tem um
pontinho de verdade no que tá sendo dito
é E você tem que trabalhar isso isso e e
mas de qualquer maneira a respeito
especificamente do Burnout Sim a gente
ouve muita groselia
incluindo doss médicos dos terapeutas
da família dos conhecidos dos
desconhecidos vocês TM ideia do que eu
ouvi na internet eu tive que fazer um
curso intensivo de lidar com haer Mas aí
você vai descobrindo a sua força de de
de começar a discernir O que é seu e o
que é do outro e não deixar as pessoas
te humilharem te menosprezem e aprender
que o que que essas pessoas estão
fazendo na sua vida por que que elas têm
a liberdade de falar isso para você é
isso que o Bernal vai nos ensinando sabe
é isso é muito interessante
né Isso é verdade
jazi
Ah vamos
lá muito obrigado viu engenharia da
saúde Qual é a relação entre Burnout e
menopausa se é que existe yes
existe sim é que tem tem a questão de
muitos médicos dizerem que estamos na
menopausa quando na verdade estamos em
barnaut tem isso também então se você é
uma mulher com mais de 45 anos saiba que
em algum momento todos os seus sintomas
vão ser colocados eh no Ah não é a idade
tá na hora disso acontecer a menopausa
mas eh como o meu o meu colapso foi aos
43 anos eu Eu só comecei a ouvir isso
mais pra frente então quando começou meu
climatério e começou terrivelmente
porque o meu corpo ainda tava muito
inflamado e tal eu comecei a ouvir que
será que você tem Burnout mesmo Será que
não é o climatério que já tinha começado
então é super legal agora a a a conexão
dos dois eu deixo PR pro médico falar
para não falar b não sem dúvida a mulher
quando passa vamos usar o Tero correto
que é o climatério né porque as pessoas
gostam de falar menopausa mas a
menopausa é só uma data né é um
aniversário da sua última menstruação né
digamos assim é uma data então o
processo todo chama climatério tá aquele
todo aqueles anos que a mulher passa que
ela fica com oscilações de humor
oscilações hormonais que é tão difícil
pra mulher aguentar que Muitas delas
mais da metade tem fogachos né que são
os calorões Então na verdade obviamente
uma pessoa que tá passando por isso vai
ter mais suscetibilidade a passar pelo
Burnout tá apesar de ser duas coisas
diferentes
então sim se a pessoa tá no climatério
ela fica mais sujeita a passar por um
Burnout Com certeza logicamente que tem
outras condições em conjunto né todas as
as condições que levam a pessoal Burnout
tem que estar presentes e não somente o
climatério ou aí pode acontecer também
da mulher no climatério fazer um homem
ficar em Burnout isso pode acontecer
também mas aí é
porque a mulher que Burn que tá normal M
ela tá totalmente na energia masculina
quando a mulher tá na energia masculina
ao lado dela tem um homem que não tá
ajudando em nada e daí a gente entra em
barnaut também V fazer alos aqui mas eu
falei falei meio brincando isso aí mas
Ah eu entendi né tô brincando eu sei eu
sei vamos lá o Burnout hoje está o que
foi a cí do Pânico no início dos anos 80
tive a cí em 84 demorei muito para para
encontrar o médico que me dessa
orientação tem razão é um bom paralelo
que você traçou aí né e a demência front
temporal pode ter consequências na no
Burnout não eu acho
que não entendi bem essa essa observação
que você tá
fazendo na verdade como eu te falei
qualquer fma de estresse crônico ele
atrapalha o hipocampo Né que é é um é
uma é uma estrutura cerebral importante
paraa memória e é um fator de risco para
as demências mais mais alheimer do que o
temporal tá não sei se eu entendi essa
sua
colocação Qual a diferença entre C de
Burnout e depressão é é bem diferente tá
esgotamento físico e mental tá muito
mais ligado ao que nós estamos falando
aqui que é o Burnout tá a depressão ela
pode acontecer numa pessoa que tá
tranquila trabalha 3 horas por dia não
tem problema nenhum na família tá todo
mundo bem não tá brigando com com o
cônjuge entende então depressão tem a
reativa né e tem a depressão que não é
reativa que é a depressão maior né e que
não tem uma explicação muito clara
porque a pessoa tá deprimida aí tem as
teorias por trás que pode ser parte
dessa depressão pode ser inflamatória
pessoa que só faz uma alimentação muito
inflamatória ou ou a questão né que é o
paradigma atual da psiquiatria que a
depressão tem origem no desequilíbrio de
neurotransmissores mas não é só isso né
tanto que 50% dos pacientes que tratam
com antidepressivo não melhora da
depressão e o antidepressivo faz
justamente aumentar os níveis de
neurotransmissores no cérebro seja a
noradrenalina ou
seja outros neurotransmissores
Associados né como a a enfim o Samurai é
quando a glândula adrenal se esgota e o
cortisol despenca não isso aí é a teoria
né da Fadiga adrenal que a gente hoje
chama de disfunção do eixo hpa viu
Samurai tá então voltando a Assunta do
NE transmissor a serotonina e neuro
adrenalina né porque os os remédios que
nós temos hoje em dia eles inibem a
recaptação desses dois tipos de
neurotransmissor então aumenta os níveis
de serotonina e noradrenalina no cérebro
Olha na minha nesse nesse período que eu
ainda não sabia o que eu tinha
exatamente e cismava muito que eu tava
com depressão e eu sabia que não eu
entendi que a gente consegue Claro
grosso modo isso para você saber que
ajuda você procura primeiro mas quando a
gente tá com depressão a gente não vê
propósito em fazer as coisas é o famoso
Ai para quê quando você tá com Burnout
que você tá muito fadigado que você tá
desanimado você faria você tem vontade
Você gostaria de fazer as coisas mas ou
o seu corpo não deixa porque tá com
muita fadiga ou você acaba priorizando
outras coisas Essa é a diferença pra
gente saber se observando se você olha
para uma coisa e fala ai para quê mais
provável que seja a depressão mas se
você falar eu go de fazer isso mas eu tô
tão cansada Provável que seja Bernal é e
muitas vezes é difícil de diferenciar
porque tem vários tipos de depressão
também né Tem uma depressão que é mais
apática o
caus É e tem uma depressão que é mais
pro lado da tristeza profunda né então
nem sempre é é fácil você diferenciar
mas obviamente que a depressão ela é uma
entidade é muito mais fácil de
diagnosticado que o Burnout porque enfim
ela não tá dependendo de uma carga de
trabalho ou de uma inadequação de
trabalho ou ou qualquer coisa do
tipo Quais exames você indica aí ó você
tá indicando exames agora aí ô
eu para que nome ai não entendi para
esse nome aí o Burnout que eles não
sabem falar Burnout Deve ser isso ah não
não eu não indico exames eu indico que
você procure um médico integrativo um
psicólogo e me siga para mudar seu
estilo de vida tem que ser as três
coisas ao mesmo tempo na paralela você
tem que procurar os profissionais que
podem te ajudar médico integrativo e um
psicólogo no mínimo Então os exames tem
que ser exames bem abrangentes tá tem
que ver função renal função hepática tem
que ver os hormônios tanto tiroidiano
quanto adrenal tem que ver hormônio
sexual tem que ver eh marcador estresso
oxidativo marcadores de inflamação de
modo geral colesterol Total frações
hemograma completo
é o exame mais abrangente possível para
ter uma ideia geral da Saúde da pessoa
certo e hoje tem exames mais avançados
por exemplo se você tiver condições
financeiras você pode fazer exames de
Aços orgânicos urinários que vê vários
marcadores de estresso oxidativo mais
avançados que vê eh marcadores de
metabolismo microbiano que vem
marcadores inclusive
de da questão dos neurotransmissores
cerebrais e tem também hoje uns exames
especializados de neurotransmissores aí
de alguns Laboratórios específico tá
ã deveria existir um Sid para disfunção
do eixo hpa mas tem tem tem tem tem o
sid de Burnout mas aí é o que eu tava
falando a o entendimento hoje do que é
Burnout é errado porque é a visão da
alopatia eles entendem como transtorno
de humor para vocês terem uma ideia a
tradução vamos dizer assim de Burnout é
síndrome do esgotamento profissional nem
isso tá certo Burnout não é vinculado só
a a reação laboral então Terci tem o
problema é a partir daí o que é feito
com
isso com
certeza entendi sim mas veja bem Samurai
não tem tem que ter necessariamente
predominância estrogênica para fazer
diagnóstico de Burnout não tá isso que
você tá falando faz sentido
mas não é uma
condição sinequanon ter predominância ou
dominância estrogênica para fazer
diagnóstico de Burnout nas mulheres
tá poxa você chegou atrasada você perdeu
os canapés você perdeu os canapés perdeu
as bebidas Poxa Aida caramba Vai ficar
gravada a Live vai ficar gravada não não
vai não eu vou pagar essa Live só de
raiva vou apagar essa Live só de
raiva Olá
le Qual que é a diferença são doenças
completamente diferentes
Cristiane TDH é déficit de atenção com
ou sem hiperatividade não tem nada a ver
com Burnout tá é a pessoa que tem
dificuldade de focar é a pessoa que não
consegue ficar quieta tá não tem nada a
ver com com questão de de de Burnout que
é eh como nós falamos esgotamento físico
e
mental o senhor é médico de Qual
especialidade então le quando eu era
ainda um médico normal quando eu não
enlouqueci não fiquei doido eu era
urologista Tá certo então eu era um
médico fiz cirurgia geral fiz urologia e
nos últimos 10 anos eu pratico a
medicina funcional integrativa de estilo
de vida tá então hoje a minha
preocupação não é mais com especialidade
a minha preocupação é tratar o ser
humano como um todo tá mas de base eu
sou o cirurgião
geral
[Música]
Ah porque paramedicina é tudo Burnout
não não tem como confundir Burnout com
climatério não tá marar e pra medicina
nada é Burnout tudo é depressão é
depressão estresse né ansiedade essas
coisas ansiedade pânico eu não DMO faz 5
anos Ô louco Pois então Elisa comarque
uma consulta com o Dr Alan porque eu
fiquei sem dormir não sei quanto tempo e
hoje menina eu acordo com a cara até
amassada que eu durmo 9 horas na noite
acho que estou sofrendo com isso tomo
remédio de dor de cabeça todos os dias
da minha vida ô não pode le tem que
melhorar isso aí viu le é que nem
remédio para dormir né que mascara né O
que tá realmente acontecendo e a você
nunca descobre você só vai
adiando
aí a Cristina dando a dica aí
ó assiste hein antes que eu apague hein
eu vou apagar hein ó ó que eu tô falando
que vou apagar hein ó lá como ficar
membro tem um botãozinho Elisa se você
tá assistindo do YouTube você vai lá
qualquer vídeo meu tem lá eh tem um
botãozinho embaixo do vídeo assim como
ser membro tá tá lá eh ser membro do da
da comunidade fechada do
canal se vocês conhecerem alguém com
Burnout querendo jogar o celular na
parede tem que ser um ssung é isso não
por favor diga a esse alguém jogar na
lixeira daqui de casa tá precisando de
de celulares eu Então tá bom
combinado Qual que é o nome da doutora
doutora Roberta Caru não sou Doutora
Não não sou não sou nem médica nem
psicóloga meu nome é Roberta carui eu
sou uma metida aqui que resolveu estudar
Burnout porque fui
bernada Tá certo então ela viveu na pele
e hoje
ajuda milhares de pessoas que passaram
pelo mesmo
problema ouro coloidal pode ajudar para
Burnout acho que não Mari acho que não
quem não consegue meditar está com
Burnout não quem não consegue meditar
praticamente quase todo mundo que não
tentou meditar por muito tempo né na
verdade eu acho que tem que insistir viu
mesmo que você faça bem pouquinho por
dia até você pegar o jeito da coisa ó
deixa eu te falar uma coisa de novo
parece que eu tô fazendo propaganda aqui
mas vai lá no meu canal de aulas a aula
mais recente é sobre meditação E lá eu
provo que todo mundo consegue meditar e
explica o que que tá acontecendo para
você não conseguir vai lá é aula 63
canal Roberta Caru momento Jabá momento
já bato com certeza
moment mas esse é o limite quando chega
a esse ponto a pessoa tá quase
desmaiando em um estado
crítico Por que ninguém responde Live
respondendo tudo ai ai ai meu deus do
céu porque que esse Dr Alan não responde
nada boa noite Dr Alan gratidão obrigado
anda é porque o pessoal não tem
paciência não Roberta é Caru é c c de
casa a r de rato u s de sapo I
Caru errou já errou
errou Mas acertou agora pronto é Caru
Caru Tá bom viu pessoal mas eh a gente
sempre deixa rolar primeiro a meia hora
da Live né
com pelo menos né Depois vai responder
as
perguntas o que que qual o que causa
problema na adrenal isso tem a ver com o
psicológico Então na verdade o
psicológico que acaba causando uma
disfunção do eixo hipó pitar adrenal tá
porque a pessoa fica muito estressada
ela ativa o tempo todo mecanismo de lut
efuga mecanismo de lut e fuga esse
mecanismo envolve a ativação da adrenal
da cortical da adrenal que é o algo que
fica acima dos rins que fica liberando
os hormônios do estresse tá que é o
cortisol sol e é adrenalina e
noradrenalina então quando esse
mecanismo é toda H toda hora ele é
disparado por exemplo esse mecanismo
serve pra gente se sobreviver né Por
Acaso se a gente é atacado por alguém a
gente tem que saber o que tem que fazer
ou você foge daquela pessoa ou ataca
aquela pessoa então você precisa ter
mais sangue circulando no seu corpo
precisa mobilizar a glicose que é a
fonte de energia para você ter energia
para correr ou para brigar então só que
quando você ativa esse mecanismo o tempo
todo você começa a desgastar o seu
organismo tá Olha acho que o melhor
jeito de entender é assim os nossos
pensamentos geram emoções e as nossas
emoções geram consequências físicas por
exemplo se você se pegar numa reunião de
trabalho com muita gente aí você falou
uma grande bobagem aí você fala a meu
Deus do céu as pessoas vão achar que que
acontece você fica com o rosto vermelho
então o seu pensamento meu Deus eu tive
o falei uma bobagem causou emoção aí de
vergonha e você teve essa consequência é
a mesma coisa só que assim cada vez que
você tem medo de ser demitido de ser
abandonado de do que vão pensar de não
dar conta você tá sinalizando pro seu
corpo que você tá em perigo aí entra
esse sistema aí de L efuga que que ele
falou então o que você tá pensando tá
causando emoções de medo que vão causar
essas consequências físicas e essa esse
é o grande problema da medicina
convencional que eles realmente acredita
que só a gente cuidando do que pensa
cuidando do do humor a gente resolve mas
tem um estrago que foi feito pelo
estresse fisicamente real no corpo o
intestino tá em disbiose o sistema
autônomo sei lá das quantas as taxas de
tá tudo confuso então assim a a origem é
emocional a consequência é física e é
isso que a medicina integrativa consegue
entender e a alopata não porque o
acontece é o seguinte Pessoal esse
mecanismo de luta e fuga ele é ativado
independente do tamanho da da ameaça tá
porque ele é uma coisa ancestral do
nosso organismo então a gente precisava
daquilo quando a gente estava nas
cavernas ainda né o homem ancestral que
não era dinossauro tá pessoal dinossauro
éa de outra época era tigre dente de
sabre era outros bichos tá então aquele
homem primitivo tinha queir fugir de um
animal selvagem ou brigar com o animal
selvagem ou caçar aquele animal né então
ativava todo esse mecanismo de
sobrevivência que e era importante pro
aquele organismo tá ter aquele Sprint né
tem aquela energia extra e aquela
circulação arterial que fica mais rápida
a pressão arterial aumenta a a
frequência cardíaca aumenta eentão é
importante para ele ter aquela reação de
fuga ou de luta agora Acontece que hoje
em dia o homem moderno ele não tem mais
esse problema do animal selvagem Mas
qualquer situação como que estressa a
pessoa o organismo não sabe diferença
disso de um leão de um tigre ou do
trânsito que tá ruim né que o trânsito
tá agitado então acaba tendo a mesma
reação no organismo e Se isso for com
acontecendo com muita frequência isso
vai desgastando todo o sistema
tá
ã que mais
aqui o ASO R ASO a r lipóico ele é muito
bom como antioxidante Tá mas ele não é
específico para tratar Burnout talvez a
consequência do Burnout mas não a causa
do Burnout tá
e Elisa estuda
enfermagem Ué não tá aparecendo aqui
travou Ah então Fica atenta Elisa que
enfermeiros são das profissões que mais
tem índice de Burnout Com certeza médico
enfermeiro tem muito Burnout também
tá
hum
o Maurílio Oi Maurílio meu amigo ele
legal meu seguidor que virou amigo que
bacana arizol Obrigado aí
viu isso é o canal do Rafael escapela é
um dos canais dele tem mais tem mais
outros dois
canais sensação de desconexão e
desinteresse Ah então era isso mesmo
despersonalização
é o antidepressivo pode disfarçar o
sintomas se for alta de noradrenalina ou
serotonina Mas a questão do cortisol no
eixo hpa não deveria ser menos
concordo com você concordo com você
jaz Conheci no evento da central
Nutrition ela me conheceu lá super
tranquilo que bom né que eu não tava
nervoso e o parkon que que tem o paron
Paul o
PT Depois você manda aí mais completinho
aí viu ômega3 ep DH ajuda ajuda sim
porque tem ação antiinflamatória e é uma
parte importante aí da membrana dos
neurônios tá essas esses Aços grassos aí
ômega3 é verdade né as pessoas são muito
críticas né quando alguém tá em Burnout
é muito complicado mesmo né É mas olha
eu aprendi uma coisa quem fala é quem
sabe que poderia tá no seu lugar e quer
que todo mundo preste atenção em você
para não prestar atenção que ele tá
dando pau também então Fica tranquila
porque essa dinâmica nunca
falha Boa noite
Marcelo não conseguir tomar decisão E e
ter muita tristeza causa fadiga
adrenal não necessariamente depende
muito das coisas que estão em em volta
disso daí
né só Responde às perguntas do Eliseu ué
tá certo só você tem que prestar atenção
mesmo se você não tá num processo porque
quando a gente se vê assim
muito vítima muito desprestigiado tô
falando sério tô falando na boa é
realmente um sinal de que a gente leva a
vida de uma forma muito estressante
porque a gente se vê sempre podendo
contar só com a gente e isso é muito é
muito
angustiante é mas é porque o pessoal às
vezes não espera o delay né É mas né
É com certeza naa Paula tem
suscetibilidade genética no Burnout
tenho certeza que sim mas não é a parte
mais
importante sim sim aí o problema deve
ser realmente as consequências da
menopausa porque na idade que você tá
Você já passou pelo climatério já houve
a menopausa que é a última data da
última menstruação e a queda de cabelo
pode ter a ver com tireoide pode ter a
ver com deficiência de nutrientes tem
que fazer uma investigação
eh realmente abrangente pra gente
entender né O que tá acontecendo com
você tá bom
Vera isso compartilhe os vídeos faço bem
que nem aquela musiquinha lá que eu
coloco nos vídeos
né tipo já ter ensaiado é a vida de
alguém pode mudar também no canal do
dror alando TR se envolva tá aí
ó estão muito vulneráveis a maioria tá
caminhando para isso a Passos largos É
verdade Ana você tem
razão exame de vitamina D não entra
entra sim Douglas entra entra sim falei
todos os exames eu falei só tá bom esse
tema da Live seria o cortisol baixo
também também cortisol baixo faz parte
desse
eu tenho vídeos aí no canal mais antigo
Só falo de cortisol tá e tem um vídeo
que eu fiz com Lúcio Lemos uma live que
é bem mais técnica tá o El lisme né Acho
que lisme né É É se você quer ver uma um
vídeo mais técnico assiste a Live que eu
fiz com o Lúcio Lemos que tá naquele
link que eu mostrei para vocês tá deixa
eu mostrar de novo o link esse aqui ó
tem a a Playlist dos vídeos anteriores
vamos
lá que mais aqui aqui
pronto não durmo estou ficando lenta
aqui na Escandinávia eles nem sabem o
que é isso Ah é Sério Elisa tá falando
sério que na Escandinávia Eles não sabem
o que que é
bnx a vida tô surpreso
Ok T Só desabafando aqui de
nada depoimento aqui do peace of
Spirit
Verônica legal ah nome dela
isso
online ficou fora de
contexto não sei que ela tá perguntando
aqui
como faz para ter consulta Ah isso eu
vou
deixar um telefone aqui tá bom para
vocês entrarem em
contato deixa
eu colocar aqui na
tela pera aí tá bom Pessoal esse é o
telefone de contato para
agendar vamos quando a gente desce Às
vez é difícil de de achar o ponto que a
gente parou aqui vamos
lá tá vendo aprender uma coisa nova hoje
hein
Verônica Obrigado
Neusa explique pessoal os benefícios de
se tonar membro então Eh nós temos esse
serviço de do canal fechado dos membros
do canal e que nós temos uma comunidade
fechada que a gente toda semana tem uma
live que eu respondo às dúvidas do
Eliseu que faz parte dessa comunidade
fechada e de outros membros porque
primeiro é do Eliseu depois dos outros
membros Eliseu é o protegidinho
oi o Eliseu é o protegidinho é o
protegidinho viu tá tá todo mundo com
raiva do Eliseu que só só respondo as
perguntas do Eliseu tá certo mas enfim e
o canal nós temos essa parte da
comunidade do canal que a gente tem um
um
uma comunidade
no no Instagram não desculpa no WhatsApp
que a gente responde a comunidade
conversa entre si e toda a semana a
gente tem uma live semanal para
responder dúvidas e para discutir al uns
artigos que eu acho interessante né
então tem essa conversa semanal com os
membros do canal nós discutimos um
artigo ou dois artigos dependendo do
tempo e tem também uma tonelada de
conteúdo gratuito de alta qualidade para
quem se inscreve na parte fechada do
canal tá
Obrigado
Aida
H é sua filha pode estar com banal tem
que ver isso aí
né é isso pode ser banal ou pode ser
realmente um quadro depressivo ansioso
tá tem o Tag né que o transtorno de
ansiedade generalizada tem que ver com
calma aí qual é o seu caso
Não entendi isso aí não mas tudo
bem imagina desculpo porque todo mundo
erra meu sobrenome viu É raro acertar de
primeira ai me passaram muito Passiflora
ja gente eu não aguentava mais ouvir
Passiflora e espirulina é né Passiflora
Você
quase plantou um maracujá na sua casa
quase o maracuj
é
né Obrigada Alê obrigada a shanda é é um
bom adaptógeno viu Robson sim o Ach
Ganda É bem interessante viu eu gosto
bastante da shaga e tem um derivado dele
que é o ksm 66 também bem legal tá
e Geralmente eu não uso só um adaptógeno
eu uso uma combinação de vários
adaptógenos Tá mas esse é um dos
melhores
já já foi respondida essa pergunta
Regina depois você volta o
vídeo Boa
noite depoimento do rauni
aqui Alguém falou em japonês
[Risadas]
aqui ah
imina ja ela tá falando é eu achei que
era o nome de alguma escritora
japonesa Alguém já perguntou sobre Não
esse aqui já foi
respondido meu filho não está bem com
crise forte ansiedade insônia perda de
memória e não consegue ficar no meio de
muita gente é aí pode ser snd do Pânico
agor fobia e não necessariamente ISO
aqui é um Burnout tá
Mas você sabe que eu percebi muita gente
eu passei eu sentia isso e muita gente
me fala que essa sensação de de você tá
num lugar com muita informação muito
movimento muito barulho aquilo começa a
te dar uma angústia Tem muita gente que
não tem transtorno de ansiedade mas que
no Burnout relata isso engraçado essa
essa esse sintoma não pode ter sim mas
po não só porque a pessoa temia né mas
pode estar também lá
Ok muito obrigado
Rane
[Música]
obgado tá vendo Deus te encaminhou para
esse
conteúdo nada é por
acaso bem eu acho que a gente já tá com
1 hora e meia de Live já tá bom
né Eu queria Então encerrar essa Live
perguntando para você Roberta Qual que é
a mensagem principal que você gostaria
que as pessoas levassem da sua história
e do seu trabalho
aí
olha eu acho que a minha
principal agenda hoje
é mudar a forma como as pessoas olham o
Burnout que é nessa cultura que a gente
vive é muito fácil a gente se assumir
como um fracassado e se conformar
mediocri a nossa vida e O interessante é
que a mediocridade estressa a gente do
mesmo jeito que a sobrecarga então a
gente é muito fácil a gente se manter
doente hoje nessa Cultura né e entender
que é um problema individual que foi um
um fracasso pessoal então o todo o
conteúdo que eu faço é para combater
essa ideia que nasce na dentro da gente
quando a gente se vê com um Burnout né
porque assim não tem como a gente ser
feliz e saudável nesse caminho e o
dinheiro não é a resposta para tudo né
então assim Precisa endurecer a gente
precisa descobrir a nossa força a gente
precisa aprender a criar oportunidade na
vida parar de se Enxergar como uma
vítima impotente que depende das
decisões dos outros e o capitalismo é
Cruel enquanto não cair o sistema nada
poderá ser feito entendeu para que a
gente possa ter uma vida digna saudável
e produtiva Então o a minha proposta
sempre no do conteúdo que eu faço é que
a gente deixe de ver o Burnout como um
fracasso como um castigo como um enorme
problema e passe a enxergar o Burnout
como uma oportunidade uma segunda chance
uma correção de Rota não tô
romantizando o o sofrimento não é isso
eu acho que se pudesse não haver Burnout
seria melhor porque ninguém merece
passar é um horror Mas uma vez que a
gente se vê nessa situação a gente
precisa entender como a gente chegou até
ali e como quando a gente começa a ver o
bernald como uma correção de Rota quando
quando a gente começa a assumir a
responsabilidade pelas escolhas que a
gente fez responsabilidade é muito
diferente de culpa a gente entende
porque que o Burnout veio paraa nossa
vida então essa sensação de que é o fim
não tenha calma que aos poucos as coisas
vão
eh se encaixando e a gente percebe que
foi só um desvio de Rota
ali muito bem eh primeiramente eu queria
agradecer muito a generosidade da Irene
mel que deixou uma contribuição aqui pro
Canal e
que mandou suas bênçãos muito obrigado
viu pelas palavras bonitas viu Irene e
aqui a Maria anjos e queria que eu
apresentasse aqui o comentário dela
estou apresentando aqui viu sinto muita
tontura Vertigem quando estou no meio de
gente sem vontade de viver procure ajuda
Maria é muito importante que você seja
assistida de uma maneira adequada viu
Eu já coloquei o meu telefone se você
quiser passar com outro profissional o
mais importante que é que você realmente
procure ajuda para você não pensar em
coisas erradas aí né pra gente não falar
especificamente o que é porque a
plataforma não gosta de certas palavras
pesadas
né obrigado viu Maria Teresa pelo
comentário então de novo Pessoal esse
aqui é o link tá de uma playlist que tem
um monte de vídeo sobre esse assunto eu
sei que hoje eu fui p técnico digamos
assim eu falei pouca coisa de medicina
de parte biológica porque eu já falei
extensivamente desse tema aqui no canal
Hoje eu queria dar uma ênfase da
história da Roberta então a gente não
teve essa ênfase muito na parte
científica Tá mas vocês pode estar
assistindo aí esse link dá acesso a
todos os vídeos do canal não sei se
todos mas a maioria dos vídeos no canal
que a gente aborda sobre esse tema tão
importante que é a fadiga crônica e o
Burnout
bem então vamos nos despedir né últimas
palavras aí Roberto é isso quem quem tá
se identificando com o que a gente falou
aqui eh procure a ajuda correta mas
procure entender melhor desse assunto em
Fontes que realmente te ajudem que
estudem a sério e que não queiram só o
engajamento sabe eh comece a a
seguir de vida de como procurar as
informações corretas ajuda correta
porque é muito importante ninguém sai
sozinho de um Burnout e muitas vezes as
pessoas que estão em volta mais
atrapalham do que ajudam então assim
procurar a ajuda correta é fundamental
por isso que eu sempre falo que tem três
frentes é médico integrativo é terapia e
é mudança de estilo de vida porque sem
isso a gente não consegue não sem dúvida
a medicina funcional integrativa só
funciona bem com a parte de estilo de
vida né senão a gente acaba tendo que
uma pessoa que toma muito suplemento
Muita vitamina muito fitoterápico mas
que não muda essencialmente o que levou
ela se tornar uma pessoa doente então é
muito importante associar essas coisas
para que tenha resultados perenes e
permanentes né aí só para terminar e aí
as pessoas começam a falar ai eu tive
dois BN ah eu tô no
qu é um
só fica melhora PI você controla e volta
então Bernal é um negócio que a gente
precisa realmente resolver da raiz não
adianta ficar tomando remédio para
amenizar os sintomas como uma forma de
continuar com o mesmo estilo de vida
fazendo as mesmas coisas nos mesmos
lugares com as mesmas pessoas no mesmo
ritmo que você não vai resolver você vai
ficar com uma Âncora amarrada no pé
carregando esse peso e sofrendo para FR
falando ai não tem tem cura Mas se a
gente coisa for
Então pessoal Muito obrigado ter
acompanhado esse vídeo passe o link
desse vídeo para alguém que você conhece
que tá passando por um problema de
fadiga crônica que pode estar com
Burnout que tem a suspeita do Burnout
que talvez esteja diagnosticado de forma
errada como depressão ansiedade crônica
então ajude a divulgar a palavra para
quem precisa né E se você se identifica
conteúdo Desse Canal considere se tornar
membro porque você vai ter acesso à Live
semana mais comigo vai ter uma atenção
muito grande da minha parte vai ter
acesso ao grupo do WhatsApp de pessoas
de excelente nível aí eh de conhecimento
trocam ideias todos os dias sobre saúde
natural sobre saúde integrativa e do
estilo de vida e ter acesso também ao
conteúdo exclusivo que só por si só vale
muito mais do que a contribuição eh
mensal de se fazer parte da comunidade
fechada Muito obrigado a todos vocês um
grande abraço nós nos vemos no próximo
vídeo o um beijo no coração você é fera